Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Wir unterbrechen unsere täglichen WM-Sendungen für eine Sondersendung zum Wechsel von Cristiano Bernhard zu Juventus Turin. Nein, Moment, von Cristiano Ronaldo. Mein Gast heißt ja Christian Bernhard. Hallo. Ja, Bernie, unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer kennen dich schon als den Italien-Experten, den man hier im Rasenfunk immer wieder hören kann. Und wir zwei haben schon vor einer Weile mal geschrieben, also sollte das irgendwie, sollte an diesen wilden Gerücht, dass Cristiano Ronaldo zu Juventus Turin wechselt, etwas dran sein, müssten wir noch mal miteinander sprechen. Und dann ging es jetzt auf einmal sehr schnell.
Sehr schnell, ja. Genau. Ich kann mich auch noch sehr gut erinnern. Wir haben gemeint, ja, schauen wir mal, ob da was sehr skeptisch, sehr zurückhaltend. Jetzt ist es über die Bühne gebracht.
Wie ist denn so das Echo in Italiens Medien?
Ja, sehr groß.
Was, sind du nicht mit der WM beschäftigt?
Überraschenderweise? Ja, das war jetzt logischerweise, also, ich glaube, das ging ungefähr vor einer Woche oder vor zehn Tagen circa, ging jetzt so langsam los. Und ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich habe es dann so mit dem Abstand mir angeschaut, weil ich eigentlich nicht wirklich gedacht habe, dass das dann so in die Richtung auch gehen könnte. Aber spätestens, muss ich sagen, vor ein paar Tagen – Juve ist ja an der Börse notiert – und vor ein paar Tagen hat Juve dann so eine kurze, kleine, nicht-sagende Meldung herausgegeben auf Druck auch der Börse, in der im Prinzip ein Knur drin stand, dass der Fußballverein Juventus sich auf dem Spielermarkt mit mehreren Namen beschäftigt. Da ist auch logischerweise nie dieser eine Name aufgetaucht. Aber ab dem Moment habe ich mir auch gedacht, gut, wenn die jetzt so was offiziell an der Börse eben ausgeben, weil dann hätten sie auch, wenn es ein Blödsinn gewesen wäre, hätten sie auch einfach sagen können, nee, da ist nichts dran, da brauchen wir nichts ausmachen. Ab da, muss ich sagen, habe ich mir gedacht, gut, anscheinend ist da wirklich was Größeres im Busch.
Und jetzt totale Euphorie oder Sprachlosigkeit, wird das auch kritisch gesehen?
Also es ist in erster Linie logisch eine Rieseneuphorie. Also ich habe jetzt sehr viele Vergleiche. Also nur mal eine kleine Idee zu vermitteln. Gestern Nachmittag, also Mittwochnachmittag, als das Ding durch war, war das logischerweise auf allen Zeitungsseiten aufmacher. Also nicht nur auf den Sportseiten, sondern wirklich übergreifend. Und das ist eine sehr, sehr große Euphorie. Also es werden jetzt schon große Vergleiche gezogen. Das ist so die eine große Umfrage, die so quer durch Italien schwebt. Wer ist jetzt der allergrößte Transfer aller Zeiten in Italien? Maradona damals zu Neapel, Ronaldo, also der echte Ronaldo damals zu Inter oder jetzt eben Cristiano Ronaldo zu Juve. Und ja, es ist logischerweise genau das, was das Fußballland Italien nach, ja, gerade dieser WM ohne Italien und nach all den Geschichten, nachdem jetzt irgendwie alles ein bisschen gelext hat und was jetzt logischerweise auch genau so transportiert wird.
Könnte natürlich auch die komplette Liga wieder ins Rampenlicht rücken. Ich weiß nicht, wann da die nächste TV-Rechteverhandlung läuft. Wenn sie Glück haben, bald.
Das ist ein sehr interessanter Punkt. Das ist nämlich sehr blöd gelaufen aus Serie A-Sicht, denn die wurden erst vor zwei Monaten… Das ist wirklich. Und das ist heute auch eine große Nummer. Die haben gemeint, wenn sie das Ding zwei Monate vorher, oder zumindest den Abschluss ein bisschen später rausgezögert hätten. Also, die haben sehr gut rausverhandelt. Die haben 1, 4 Milliarden rausgeholt, was sehr, würde ich sagen, sportlich ist. Aber es gab heute schon in der Gazette dann so Schätzungen von Experten, die gemeint haben, allein doch den einen Namen wären wahrscheinlich noch mal zwischen 10 und 20 Prozent mehr drin gewesen.
Unfassbar. Was sind das für Zeiten? Wenn wir uns eh schon im Bereich der fabelhaft hohen Zahlen bewegen, magst du uns mal kurz die Ziffern referieren, die man so weiß über den Wechsel-Ablöse-Gehalt?
Das Schöne ist ja eben, wir haben ja schon kurz gesprochen, Juve ist an der Börse notiert. Das heißt, die Ablösezahlen sind da sehr, sehr transparent. Das gibt es auch seit gestern Nachmittag, das offizielle Kommuniqué von Juve. Und da steht schön drin, dass er erst mal 100 Millionen in zwei Raten bezahlbar kostet. Und dazu kommen noch 12 Millionen Euro, anscheinend ein Art Solidaritätszuschlag, irgendwie FIFA-Summe. Also im Prinzip landen anscheinend bei real 112 Millionen Euro. Das ist die offizielle Summe, die ist bestätigt, die ist schwarz auf weiß auf dem Markt. Beim Gehalt gibt es jetzt logischerweise von Juve kein offizielles Statement. Aber, was in Italien überall rauf und runter geschrieben wird, steht das wohl angeblich bei 31 Millionen Euro netter. Pro Jahr, für vier Jahren. Ja, was ich eigentlich die krasse, unfassbar krasse Zahl finde. Also nicht falsch verstehen. Ich finde, 100 Millionen kann ich jetzt auch relativ wenig damit anfangen. Aber man hat in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren auch schon Zahlen in ähnlichen Bereichen über andere Spieler gehört. Also das ist der eine Punkt. Aber logischerweise, wenn ich jemanden im Jahr 31 Millionen netter überweisen will, dann ist das noch italienischem Steuerrecht. Sind das knapp 60 Millionen brutto. Und das halt jedes Jahr ist eine nette Zahl.
Okay, ich meine, dass die Zahlen hoch sind und dass die einen umhauen, daran hat man sich ja irgendwie schon gewöhnt. Und es würde einen fast wundern, wenn einen das Gehalt von Christian Ronaldo nicht mehr umhauen würde. Was ich aber interessant finde, war Juve nicht der Verein, der ganz lange keine hohen Gehälter gezahlt hat, unter anderem wegen der Nähe zu Fiat. Das hatte ich mal so gelesen.
Würde ich so nicht sagen. Also in den letzten Jahren war Juve – da haben wir uns ja auch schon glaube ich ein, zwei Mal unterhalten – ich hatte immer so das Gefühl, dass Juve hat so sportlich schon in den letzten Jahren so peu à peu den Schritt auch nach ganz oben zumindest den Anschluss gefunden. Jetzt logischerweise nicht auf einer Ebene mit Real, Barca, vielleicht auch Bayern, aber sie sind immer näher gekommen. Aber irgendwie hatte ich immer das Gefühl, dass sie so ein bisschen, also auf sehr, sehr hohem Niveau, so ein bisschen Understatement betrieben haben. Also super organisiert, sehr gute Transferaktivitäten, da kann man vielleicht auch noch drauf zu sprechen, aber halt nicht dieses große Knallerding sozusagen. Die Gehälter hingegen, die sind in Italien immer, die werden relativ offen diskutiert und es ist zum Beispiel so, Gonzalo Higuain hat im letzten Jahr bei Juve Netto 7, 5 verdient. Wenn man das jetzt umrechnet, sind es auch 15 brutto. Also ich glaube, ein Fehler, der manchmal gemacht wird, diese Zahlen, wenn die miteinander verwürfelt werden, in Deutschland, glaube ich, werden sehr oft die brutto gehältert. Genau, und in Italien ist eigentlich immer die Rede von Netto. Also wenn einer in Italien, wenn irgendwo steht, der verdient 5, da verdient der eigentlich brutto 10. Und deswegen hat Juve da in den letzten Jahren auch schon sehr, sehr, sehr gute Gehälter gezahlt. Also wie gesagt, in Italien, die Baller verdienen anscheinend 7 Netto, Buffon hatte 6 oder 6, 5 Netto, Bokbah hatte damals auch, bevor dann zur PSG, 6 Netto. Also die sind schon in Bereichen auch, würde ich sagen, wo die auch mit den europäischen sehr, sehr Spitzenclubs auch sehr gut mithalten können. Definitiv, genau.
Aber das heißt, das, was ich da gelesen hatte, ich weiß leider gerade nicht mehr wo, das ist eher dann aber ein Mythos, dass Juve ganz lange keine hohen Gehälter gezahlt hätte, die Argumentation war, dass man es dann den 4 Mitarbeitern am Band im Werk nicht mehr verkaufen hätte können.
Nee, würde ich so nicht sagen. Das ist nämlich jetzt auch ein interessanter Punkt. Du sprichst ja Fiat schon an. Fiat, also die Agnelli-Familie ist ja immer noch der große, ja, die Eigentümerfamilie im Prinzip hinter Juve, die hinter Juve steht. Und die ist organisiert. Ich weiß nicht, wollen wir vielleicht gleich schon kurz ins Detail rein? Ja, klar. Es gibt diese Exor-Holding, nennt sich die. Da ist im Prinzip alle Aktivitäten der Agnelli-Familie. Und die Agnelli-Familie ist in Italien unfassbar groß. Da ist eben Fiat Chrysler zum Beispiel, ist die eine Riesenmarke, logischerweise. Dann ist Ferrari, hängt da ja auch mit drin. Und diese Exor-Gesellschaft, die wird der Vorstandsvorsitzende, das ist John Elkern, der schreibt sich jetzt nicht Agnelli, ist aber ein Agnelli-Sprössling, also ein Enkel von Agnelli auch. Und der ist jetzt im Prinzip der Cousin von Andrea Agnelli, vom Juve-Präsidenten. Ist, glaube ich, auch erst hoch 30, also auch in einem sehr, sehr jungen Alter noch, für so eine hohe Position. Und die haben jetzt in den letzten Jahren wirklich, also Andrea Agnelli ist seit 2010 bei Juve ins Roder gekommen, und die haben jetzt in den letzten Jahren wirklich Schritt für Schritt dieses Juve-Produkt halt auch einfach wieder gerade nach außen hin versucht, immer Schritt für Schritt größer zu machen. Und das ist heute logischerweise die Krönung. Und der Punkt, den du ansprichst, es gab gestern schon Streikankündigungen, im italienischen Fiat-Werk, weil es logischerweise teilweise an der Basis so angerapfen wegen, ja plötzlich für den guten Fußballer da, habt ihr ja sehr viele Millionen übrig. Es gibt sehr viele Fiat-Arbeiter, die in Lohnausgleichskasse sind, die in Kurzarbeit teilweise sind. Angeblich sind die Fiat-Löhne in italienischen Werken seit 10 Jahren nicht mehr angepasst worden. Also das wird definitiv auch auf dieser Ebene, schätze ich noch zumindest, Auswirkungen als so, was die öffentliche Darstellung betrifft, haben.
Ja auch insgesamt in Italien. Wir haben keine da niederliegende Wirtschaft, aber auch nichts so florierend wie in anderen europäischen Ländern. Das ist dann schon ein Nebenthema, aber man sieht halt auch an dem Beispiel wieder der Sport und das Rampenlicht und die Sensation, dass man diesen Spieler jetzt bei Juve spielen sieht, das überstreitet dann auch vieles. Du hast einen Namen fallen lassen, über den würde ich gerne ganz kurz sprechen, nämlich Gigi Buffon. Irronisch, dass die zwei jetzt nicht mehr zusammen in einem Team spielen werden, weil er zu PSG gewechselt ist.
Ich habe ja gestern auch gedacht, was sich der Buffon wohl in dem Moment gedacht hat. Ja, schwierig. Also ich glaube, dass erstens mal, es gab jetzt auch in Italien viele so Gerüchte vom Wegen. An Alegre war er ja auch real dran vor ein paar Wochen, als er dann zurückgetreten ist. Da kam dann von ihm relativ schnell, dass der gemeint, ich stehe zu Juve und ich möchte bei Juve weitermachen. Da wurden jetzt auch so Theorien gesponnen, vom Wegen wusste er damals vielleicht schon, dass Cristiano Ronaldo – nein, glaube ich alles nicht. Genauso wird Buffon logischerweise auch mit sowas nicht gerechnet haben. Buffon, wir haben es damals schon mal kurz thematisiert, das war auch passend auch zur Juve-Politik, muss man eben sagen. Das war im Prinzip so abgesprochen vor ungefähr einem Jahr schon, dass es in die Richtung geht, dass dann Buffon eben noch mal so eine starke Saison spielt und für sich selbst den Anspruch eben hat, ich möchte noch weiterspielen, weil ich einfach auf sehr hohem Niveau noch mich fit fühle, hat der dazu geführt, dass die das eigentlich auf sehr saubere Art und Weise eben gemacht haben, diese Trennung, sage ich mal. Nicht dass es jetzt bleibt, logischerweise genau das Ding. Also ich möchte nicht wissen, wenn nächste Saison PSG gegen Juve in einem wichtigen Champions-League-Spiel gegeneinander spielen, wird es eine sehr…
Vor allem, es ging ihm ja um den Champions League. Die Chancen sind jetzt mutmaßlich schon ein bisschen gestiegen, was uns ja aber ein bisschen zu der sportlichen Bewertung führt. Cristiano Ronaldo ist 33 Jahre alt, hat einen Vier-Jahres-Vertrag bekommen. Kann man auf der einen Seite sagen, unglaublich für jemanden in diesem Alter so viel Geld auszugeben. Man kann aber auch argumentieren, also wenn irgendjemand sich fit hält, bei der WM wieder einer der schnellsten Spieler des Turniers. An der Schnelligkeit merkt man es ja. Ausdauer kannst du trainieren und andere weite ich dir auch holen. Schnelligkeit, die verlierst du im Alter. Wie wird denn das sportlich eingeordnet?
Ehrlich gesagt war bis jetzt, auch wenn es vielleicht ein bisschen blöd klingt, noch gar nicht so riesig, die sportliche Einholung da. Also, was ich damit sagen will, logischerweise wurden sofort der Klassiker in Italien, immer wenn ein großer Name kommt, kommen sofort die voraussichtliche Aufstellung. So spielt Juve 2018 und 2019 mit Cristiano Ronaldo. Klar gibt es die und klar...
Lass mich raten, er spielt auf dem linken Flügel?
Schwierig, weil da muss ja Mario Mandzukic nach hinten arbeiten, also wahrscheinlich wird er da nicht an ihm vorbeikommen. Logisch ist das ein großes Thema, aber es war bis jetzt noch viel mehr diese Riesen-Nummer, ein oder bekanntes Sportler der Welt der letzten 15 Jahre. Er kommt jetzt einfach in die Liga, kommt zu Juve und das hat wirklich alles überstrahlt. Aber eben zum Sportlichen zu kommen, ja, ich sag mal so, Juve war davor schon nicht schlecht aufgestellt ohne Cristiano Ronaldo. Was jemand in den letzten Jahren auch sportlich gesehen hat in der Champions League. Und ja, ich bin jetzt einfach mal gespannt, wie Herr Legre das vorne gerade im Offensivbereich moderiert. Also fangen wir mal so an, da vorne werden nicht alle bleiben. Und der erste Name, der eigentlich auch schon bevor Ronaldo, auch bevor diese ganze Kiste so heiß wurde, eigentlich rauf und runter diskutiert wurde, war Gonzalo Heguin, wo schon eigentlich ein bisschen länger im Raum stand, dass der vielleicht zu Geld gemacht werden könnte.
Ist das sportlich begründet?
Nicht insofern, dass Juve oder so sehr mit ihm unzufrieden gewesen wäre. Das nicht. Es ging einfach darum, dass man vielleicht gemerkt hat, dass er vielleicht auch ein bisschen so neue Impulse möchte. Es ist auch, dass man nicht unterschätzen darf, er saß auch in ein paar wichtigen Spielen, zuletzt sogar auf der Punk. Zum Beispiel im Pokalfinale, was einem wie Heguin jetzt logischerweise auch nicht so schmeckt. Aber wie gesagt, der Konkurrenzkampf war davor schon sehr groß. Und die Tatsache, dass Maruzio Sarri Chelsea übernehmen wird, was angeblich auch wieder sehr, sehr heiß wird und anscheinend jetzt wirklich auch dem Mix bald vor dem Abschluss steht, hat da eigentlich schon durchklingen lassen, dass das ein Abnehmer sein könnte. Ein sehr interessanter Punkt ist auch, wir haben das Geld ja schon ein bisschen angesprochen, werden wir auch wahrscheinlich noch kurz darüber reden, wie Juve das versucht, rezufinanzieren. Also mit dem Higoin kannst du ja nicht nur zum einer Seite noch netten Batzen Ablöse generieren, sondern du sparst dir halt auch ein umfassbar hohes Gehalt, eben 15 Millionen brutto pro Jahr. Wenn man das jetzt noch mit Buffon dazu nimmt, der ja auch schon weg ist, dann gibt es schon erste Berechnungen, die sagen, dass allein, wenn Higoin auch noch wechseln würde und Buffon, der ja schon weg ist, wäre das eine jährliche Einsparung von 20 Millionen Euro, nur an Gehalt. Das ist jetzt immer nur das Gehalt, da ist noch gar nicht die Ablösesumme, die Potenziale von Higoin drin. Also das sind auch so Sachen, da wird Juve auf jeden Fall noch Geld auch mit dem aktuellen Spielermaterial generieren.
Was muss Juve so ungefähr machen, damit man innerhalb des Financial Fairplays kommt? Da wissen wir ja, da ist die UEFA dahinter wie ein scharfer Wachhund.
Ja, ich glaube, da schaut es eben wie gesagt gar nicht so schlecht aus. Also angeblich ist es so, dass man darauf irgendwie pro Saison nicht mehr als ein Minus von 100 Millionen Euro oder so haben, an Transfer-Ausgaben. Da steht Juve jetzt auch trotz dieser 100 erstmal für Ronaldo gar nicht so schlecht da. Da wurden ein paar kleinere Namen schon wieder weiterverkauft, wo so schnell mal ein Patzen an 20-25 Millionen Euro zusammenkommt.
Man hat ja auch ganz viele Leihspieler.
Genau, da werden dann auch manchmal Namen, die hier eigentlich gar nicht auf dem Tablett sind. Da geht dann einer mal für 6 Millionen da hin, unter anderem für 7 Millionen dorthin und das summiert sich. Dann ist ja nicht nur Higuaín. Also bei Higuaín sind angeblich momentan so Summen wie 50-60 Millionen im Raum, die sie wohl hoffen oder auch glauben generieren zu können. Rogani, der innenverteidigte Italienische, ist anscheinend auch sehr heißer Kandidat bei Chelsea, weil Sarri ihn noch früher von Empoli kennt. Da geht es auch zwischen 30-40 Millionen, warbern da jetzt einfach.
Aber bräuchte Juve nicht langsam mal jüngere Innenverteidigungen?
Das ist logisch genau ein guter Punkt. Da bin ich jetzt auch sehr gespannt, weil Rogani eigentlich der ist, der auch dafür steht, dass er eigentlich den nächsten Schritt dann hinter Wardsali und Chiellini dann eben auch machen könnte. Also da wäre ich noch abwarten, ob das dann auch genauso passiert. Aber nochmal, da ist Spielermaterial da, von dem sich Juve trennen kann und auch wird, wo ich glaube, dass sie erstmal wegen Financial Forbear nicht in große Probleme kommen werden.
Der Name Du Baller wird jetzt auch immer wieder gehandelt, weil er halt einfach ein so herausragender Spieler ist. Ich hätte von der Distanz aus gesagt, wer der letzte Spieler, den ich abgeben würde als Juve. Weil ja jeder sieht, was der jetzt schon kann und wie jung der noch ist.
Der wird auch nicht gehandelt. Also klar wird er immer wieder von Zeitungen aufgenommen und logischerweise. Aber ich glaube, die Baller ist bei Juve intern kein Thema. Den auch nicht für annähernd irgendeine Summe. Es gab vor einer Woche oder vor zehn Tagen ungefähr, bevor auch noch das Ronaldo-Ding losging, ist der Name Pjanic durch den Blätterwald gerauscht, weil angeblich Barcelona sehr interessiert sein soll, was ich mir auch sehr gut vorstellen kann, so vom Spielertyp her. Aber auch da, also da könnten sie logischerweise auch auf einem Schlag sehr viel Geld generieren. Aber auch da glaube ich nicht. Ich habe das Gefühl und man hat es auch immer wieder so bei den Äußerungen von Marotta und von Alegre, auch von anderen, dass gerade so Pjanic und Tibala ist so eine Offensiv-Achse, auf die Juve sehr setzt. Also ich glaube nicht, dass die zwei Juve kurzfristig verlassen werden.
Ich hätte noch eine Frage. Da müssen wir zwar jetzt ein bisschen in Spekulieren rein, aber warum glaubst du, hat Ronaldo diesen Wechsel gemacht?
Ja, gute Frage. Also was man von italienischer Seite erst mal sagen kann, es war schon als Ronaldo dieses nicht so ganz hässliche Tor in der letzten Champions League Saison in Turin erzielt hat, also diesen relativ anzelligen Fallrückzieher, hat ihm damals schon sehr, sehr, sehr gut gefallen, dass er Standing Ovation bekommen hat.
Von den Juve-Fans?
Von den Juve-Fans, genau, in Turin. Und das wurde damals schon, hat er damals, glaube ich, sogar er schon auch danach thematisiert, dass er sich da auch, unter Anführungszeichen, geehrt gefühlt hat. Und ich glaube bei einem Spieler wie Cristiano Ronaldo, ohne ihn jetzt persönlich zu kennen, aber…
Dem geht es nicht um den Applaus.
Wo halt doch auch, glaube ich, eine Rolle spielt, diese Wertschätzung, diese Äußere, würde ich sagen, dass das schonmal nicht ein ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz kleiner Punkt ist. Deswegen würde ich jetzt logischerweise nicht sagen, dass so einer dann dahin wechselt. Aber ich glaube, das war sicher nicht, nicht hinderlich.
Vor allem, wenn man weiß, dass bei Real Madrid es jetzt zum ersten Mal, ich denke seitdem, Cristiano Ronaldo überhaupt, als Spieler seine Tore schießt. Und er hat ja unglaublich viele Tore da geschossen, über 450 in 438 Spielen, unglaublich. Aber da wurde ja zum ersten Mal Kritik laut. Er hatte eine Dürrephase zu Beginn der Saison, in der er nicht getroffen hat. Da dachte man schon kurz, das könnte jetzt aber sogar eng werden, auch mit der Torjägerkanone. Dann hat er mal kurz wieder aufgedreht und hat doch wieder seine über 30 Treffer, glaube ich, gemacht. Aber es gab schon zum ersten Mal eigentlich ein bisschen Kritik an der gesamten Mannschaft, die nicht so toll gespielt hat, vor allem in der Liga, aber eben auch in Ronaldo. Und da passt es natürlich sehr gut zusammen, dass er dann bei einem anderen Verein ihm so gehuldigt wird.
Das ist Hulding, genau. Was man auch in Spanien dann noch hört, ist ja auch, dass es da, glaube ich, nicht nur eben um sportliche Punkte ging, sondern auch diese ganze Steueraffärennummer.
Ja, aber nimmt denn Italien jetzt doch Wirtschaftsflüchtlinge auf?
Jetzt kommt, glaube ich, ein sehr interessanter Punkt, der, glaube ich, hierzulande noch gar nicht groß auf dem Zettel ist. Es gibt in Italien seit dem letzten Jahr Teil einer Gesetzereform, ein neues Steuergesetz, in dem finanzkräftige Menschen aus dem Ausland, die nach Italien ziehen, für ihre Einkünfte, die sie im Ausland erzielen, also sprich nicht in Italien, eine Pauschalzahlung pro Jahr von 100.000 Euro zu leisten haben.
Das heißt, wenn er seine Marketingrechte, die er kurz vor dem Prozess, bevor das verboten wurde, hatte er seine Marketingrechte für die nächsten Jahre nochmal überschrieben an so eine Firma, die in Steuerparadiesen beheimatet ist. Und alle Sponsorengelder vereinfacht gesprochen, z.B. wird er dann einmal, also er muss es ja jetzt versteuern, man weiß jetzt, dass es die Kondition gibt, das heißt einmal 100.000 Euro und die Sache ist gegessen.
Ich habe mich da nochmal eingelesen, es ist angeblich wirklich so, dass es betrifft jetzt logischerweise nicht das Juve-Gehalt, also auf die 30 Millionen Netto oder 31 Millionen Netto wird der ganz normalen Steuersatzzahlen wie jeder andere Italiener auf. Aber es geht ja um die sehr, sehr hohen Einkünfte bei ihm, die logisch an Sponsoren, an Werbegeldern außenrum fließen. Es gibt da Schätzungen, dass das anscheinend pro Jahr um die 55 Millionen Euro sind bei einem Herrn Cristiano Ronaldo. Und wenn man jetzt, nehmen wir einfach mal an, die Summe ist nicht ganz verkehrt, wenn man dann auf die 100.000 Euro einmalig zahlt pro Jahr und der italienische Staat dann sagt, so mit dieser einmaligen Zahlung sind wir quasi raus, haben wir damit kein Problem mehr, dann würde ich jetzt einfach mal der Achse Ronaldo Mendes auch unterstellen, was heißt unterstellen, ist das falsche Wort, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass dieser Punkt nicht gerade hinderlich war bei dieser Nummer. Angeblich, was auch noch dazu gehört, dass dieses zu Familienangehörige, für die sind 25.000 Euro fällig, auch so eine Basalzahlung. Ich könnte mir jetzt vorstellen, ohne seine genauen Besitzverhältnisse zu kennen, dass vielleicht auch die eine oder andere Firma auf eben Familienangehörige von ihm vielleicht auch noch läuft. Also ich glaube, der gute Mann kann, wird da finanziell eine sehr, sehr schöne Nummer daraus machen können und ich würde jetzt einfach mal vermuten, dass das auch ein Mitgrund gespielt hat.
Interessant, dass man das wirklich noch gar nicht gehört hat. Auch Wahnsinn, dass es so eine Regelung gibt.
Die wurde von der italienischen Regierung letztes Jahr. Die Idee dahinter war auch, einfach ein neues finanzkräftiges Publikum quasi ins Land zu holen und neue Summen zu generieren und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass Cristiano Ronaldo jetzt einer der Ersten ist, so einer der sehr großen Fische, der da daraus seine finanzielle Freude zieht.
Ist es nicht faszinierend? Wir hatten damals beim Wechsel von David Beckham nach Real Madrid die Lex Beckham in Spanien. Nachdem man eben einen Höchsteuersatz von, ich glaube, 25 Prozent oder also sehr, sehr gering hatte, wurde inzwischen wieder aufgehoben. Jetzt haben wir hier eine Vani geplant, aber nennen wir sie einfach Lex Ronaldo. Ich vereinfache jetzt das Rachensportteil. Ist ja wirklich interessant. Und gleichzeitig entzieht er sich natürlich auch der spanischen Juristiktion. Also sowohl die spanischen Steuerbehörden gucken natürlich jetzt ganz genau hin bei Cristiano Ronaldo, als auch er hat da eine hohe Strafe zahlen müssen und gilt als vorbestraft. Darf sich nichts mehr zu Schulden kommen lassen. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, jetzt auch Bereich der Spekulation, aber dass es sich dann auch gut anfühlt, sich in einem anderen Staat aufzuhalten, in dem man diese ganzen Restriktionen oder diese Vorverurteilung im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes nicht hat.
Würde ich eins zu eins unterschreiben, ja. Ohne logischerweise auch die genauen Details zu kennen, aber ich glaube, sowas ist ein sehr angenehmer Nebeneffekt.
Und was glaubst du, wird das mit der Serie A machen? Wir haben es vorhin schon kurz thematisiert, das mit den TV-Rechten ist natürlich wirklich, also was für ein Pech. Unglaublich. Jetzt haben wir hier eine Liga, haben wir ja schon häufiger hier thematisiert, mit zurückgehenden Zuschauerzahlen, nicht immer ganz einfach nach außen vermarktbar, aber immer dieses strahlende Juventus Turin, was auch gegen alle Widerstände, egal welcher Spieler da weggekauft wurde, sie standen immer fast, immer im Champions-League-Halbfinale, außer sie mussten gegen Real vorher ran, dann sind sie früher rausgegangen. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir jetzt zum Beispiel aber auch einen AC Milan, der so ein bisschen im Schatten der WM von den europäischen Wettbewerben ausgeschlossen wurde, wo die Besitzerfrage sehr unklar ist, weil der chinesische Besitzer irgendwie die Darle nicht finanzieren konnte. Und jetzt gibt es einen amerikanischen Besitzer, der aber nach Käufern sucht und angeblich werden noch keine Anfragen eingegangen. Das habe ich jetzt allerdings nur bei Twitter so rumfliegen sehen.
Ja, es ist eine sehr unübersichtliche Situation. Genau, es gab anscheinend einen sehr großen Interessanten aus den USA, sehr finanzkräftig, mit dem konnte sich angeblich der chinesische bisherige Besitzer nicht einigen. Also ja, es bringt es auf den Punkt, wie du gesagt hast, sehr undurchsichtig und wird sich zeigen, in welche Richtung es geht, dass es keine Interessanten gibt. Also angeblich gibt es schon Interessanten. Die Frage ist halt, wer da jetzt zu welchen Koordinationen dann noch wie was verkaufen möchte. Aber man kann es ja ziemlich einfach auf den Punkt bringen, dass es momentan alles sehr unübersichtlich ist und wird sich logischerweise auch zeigen müssen, in welche Richtung es geht.
Und was ich damit sagen wollte, ohne da jetzt zu tief in den Teil bei AC Milan reinzusteigen, das hat ja auch eine Wirkung für die Liga. Ein Verein darf nicht an den internationalen Wettbewerben teilnehmen. Eine der wichtigsten vier Vereine, würde ich sagen, mit AC Inter, Napoli und Juve aktuell, würde ich sagen, sind das die großen vier.
Und auch Roma noch.
Ah ja klar, Roma und Lazio. Jetzt kommt aber Cristiano Ronaldo in diese Liga. Das hat ja eine Außenwirkung, aber das hat ja auch eine Innenwirkung. Glaubst du, dass das die Serie A nachhaltig beeinflussen kann, vielleicht sogar wieder auf ein altes Level hebt vom Zuschauerzuspruch her, von der Medienaufmerksamkeit her, von der internationalen Strahlkraft her, wie man es vielleicht in den 90ern hatte?
Also ich glaube, die internationale Strahlkraft, glaube ich wirklich daran, dass allein durch diesen Namen jetzt einfach ein unfassbar neuer Impuls da ist. Juve hat auf Social-Media-Kanälen, also Instagram, Twitter, Facebook, um die 50 Millionen Follower. Cristiano Ronaldo kommt mit einem Schlag auf 330 Millionen, also nur mal so eine Zahl im Raum zu werfen. Und dass jetzt, glaube ich, einfach jeder Fokus auf diesen Mann gerichtet sein wird, egal, ob der am Wochenende in Frosinone spielt oder in Sao Paulo, ist glaube ich erst mal so. Deswegen glaube ich ja, dass da wirklich von außen einfach ein sehr, sehr großer Scheinwerferlicht drauf sein wird. Intern ist es ja so, was du ja auch zwischen den Zeilen durchgeklungen hast lassen, Juve war in den letzten Jahren schon sehr dominant in Italien. Sechsmal in Folge? Siebenmal.
Siebenmal.
Das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich durch ihn nicht weniger werden, das ist richtig. Was jetzt die ersten Verantwortlichen auch einfach so ein bisschen hoffen, ist einfach, dass sich die anderen durch diese Nummer halt auch angespornt fühlen, vielleicht auch irgendwie vielleicht ein bisschen ins Risiko gehört zu gehen. Ich will jetzt Risiko nicht falsch verstehen, nicht ins finanzielle Risiko, sondern zu sehen, zu hoffen, dass die jetzt anhand dieser Strahlkraft, anhand dieser Sogwirkung vielleicht auch ein bisschen davon profitieren können. Ob das so kommen wird, wird sich zeigen. Ich sag mal so, Inter ist auf keinem schlechten Weg, finde ich, wie sie es machen. Die sind jetzt auch zum ersten Mal wieder Champions League, haben sich meiner Meinung nach auch im Transfermarkt jetzt erstmal sehr gut verhalten. Roma und Napoli haben es die letzten Jahre eigentlich schon gut gemacht. Alles, wie es dann kommt, wird sich zeigen. Das ist logisch Zukunftsmusik. Aber ich glaube erstmal einfach dieser Fokus ist alleine durch diese Marke Cristiano Ronaldo erstmal schon wieder viel mehr nach Italien fallen, als es in den letzten Jahren so war.
Die Marke Cristiano Ronaldo wechselt zur Marke Juventus Turin. Die haben sich ja auch so neu formiert und das wirkt ja schon alles irgendwie auch aus einem Guss. Glaubst du, dass es sportlich vielleicht in der Liga ähnlich werden könnte? Also war es ja im Grunde schon vorher so wie hier mit dem FC Bayern in Deutschland, dass du sagst, die nationalen Spiele verlieren dann auch, wenn wir jetzt mal den ersten Ronaldo-Hype abziehen, vielleicht irgendwann ihren Reiz und es geht wirklich nur noch ums Abschneiden in der Champions League?
Das ist definitiv eine Sache, die man im Blick behalten soll. Also wie gesagt, wir haben ja kurz mal die Offensive thematisiert, wenn wir das vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz machen, selbst wenn man den Higuin weglässt, wenn wir schon davon reden, er wird verkauft werden, dann haben wir jetzt Cristiano Ronaldo, Tibala, Mandzukic, Douglas Costa, Quadrado, Bernardescu. Das sind… Pjanic lassen wir jetzt erstmal mittelvergehen. Das sind sechs Offensive, logisch nicht alle im Zentrum, auch auf Außen. Da könnte man sich jetzt zum Beispiel erstmal nur, wenn man das nur so erstmal fantasiemäßig macht, könnte ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass am Wochenende in Frosinone halt drei von denen spielen und dann aber am Mittwoch in der Champions League halt die drei anderen, die jetzt qualitativ jetzt, glaube ich, nicht so viel schlechter sind oder zumindest nicht. Also in der Liga wird das auch wahrscheinlich so weiter hinreich und dann kann man logischerweise die Fragen stellen, ob sie nicht zu sehr, zu viel alles erdrücken. Das Einzige, das vielleicht hier manchmal eben haben wir auch schon thematisiert, ja, es stimmt, Juve hat in den letzten Jahren immer am Ende gewonnen, aber – und da sehe ich schon einen kleinen Unterschied zu Deutschland, zur Bundesliga und zu den Bayern – in den letzten Jahren war immer, so einmal war es Napoli, einmal war es die Roma, ziemlich lange, sehr nah dran. Am Ende des Tages ist schon klar, der Output war dann derselbe, deswegen wenn nur einer von außen sagt, siebenmal ist die langweiligste Liga der Welt, kann man logischerweise so sehen. Aber der Weg dorthin war schon nicht ohne. Und vielleicht eine kleine Erinnerung dazu nur, Napoli hat letztes Jahr 91 Punkte gemacht, also mit 38 Spieltagen, ist schon klar, aber 91 Punkte und damit wurde angeblich, das wurde hochgerechnet, werden noch jede Mannschaft in jeder großen Liga Meister geworden, nur in diesem einen Jahr hat Juve halt 94 geholt. Also nur zur Einordnung.
Und Napoli hatte doch auch, glaube ich, drei oder vier Spieltage vor Schluss, hatte man doch das Spiel gegen Juve und hat in der 94. Minute nur zu eins kassiert.
Genau.
Der berühmte Juvedusel.
Nee, umgekehrt, Napoli hat das ja sogar gewonnen in Turin.
Achso, stimmt, aber dann danach haben sie es dann leider.
Also, nochmal, das ist jetzt logisch alles Zukunft ums Sieg. Die Juve-Dominanz wird deswegen jetzt erst mal kurzfristig kleiner werden, das ist schon klar.
Aber meinst du, dass die anderen Vereine im Rahmen ihrer Möglichkeiten irgendwie versuchen, dem etwas entgegenzusetzen? Also, scherzhaft habe ich schon bei uns im Forum unter mitmach.de die Frage gelesen, ob es dann Messi zu Napoli wechselt, damit man die alte Rivalität auch weiter ziehen kann.
Ich weiß, was du meinst, ja. Ich glaube, du hast es ganz gut getroffen im Rahmen ihrer Mittel schon. Also, Napoli macht das ja schon seit Jahren, finde ich, sehr, sehr gut, weil sie eigentlich sehr wenige ihrer Leistungsträger abgeben. Und wenn sie abgeben, haben sie bis jetzt eigentlich auch zumindest es immer wieder geschafft, dann auch relativ gleichwertigen Ersatz zu finden. Wie gesagt, Inter ist mir klar, war in den letzten Jahren nicht sehr präsent, hat auch viele Fehler gemacht. Aber gerade in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren gehen die in eine gute Richtung. Die haben sich jetzt mit Nengolan, mit Defry von Lazio, Hassamoua, mit dem jungen Martinez, dem Stürmer aus Argentinien, der in Südamerika sehr gehypt hat, finde ich auch sehr gut. Also auf dem Papier erst mal weiterentwickelt. Alles weiter wird sich zeigen. Ich glaube, die wissen alle – und da kann man den Vergleich logischerweise ziehen – logisch ist Juve das in Italien, was Bayern in Deutschland ist. Also Juve hat halt einfach diese Strahlkraft, hat auch durch die letzten Jahre einfach durch das, sage ich mal, businessmäßige, dass sie halt einfach sehr gut gemacht haben. Weil das darf man nicht vergessen, vielleicht als eine ganz kleine Klammer. Als Agnelli 2010 Juve übernommen hat, stand Juve alles andere als gut da. Die waren zweimal in Serie siebter und haben sehr blöd aus der Wäsche geguckt. Und jetzt haben die halt innerhalb von sieben Jahren einfach auch auf Manager-Ebene, auf Business-Ebene einfach sehr, sehr viel richtig gemacht. Logischerweise auch mit dem eigenen Stadion. Genau, richtig. Und da ist allen anderen schon bewusst, dass da Juve jetzt erstmal nicht in Reichweite, glaube ich, ist, was das Gesamtkonstrukt betrifft. Aber ich glaube, eben sportlich hat man schon gesehen, dass man eben auch, gerade wie die Roma im letzten Jahr auch Champions League gezeigt hat, wie Napoli jetzt seit zwei, drei Jahren, dass man da schon auch zumindest mal eine lange Zeit mithalten kann. Der Rest wird sich dann logischerweise zeigen.
Ja, auch ob irgendwas von dem eventuell jetzt eintretenden Stürmer Domino in Deutschland ankommt, ich bin mir da ehrlich gesagt nicht so sicher. Die Gedankenspiele gehen mir da immer ein bisschen um zu viele Ecken eigentlich. Ich könnte mir jetzt also Higuain zu Chelsea ja und dann kann man aber glaube ich schon relativ schnell dicht machen. Irgendjemand wird sich real noch holen, allein weil sie jemanden holen müssen. Das ist auch als Signal an die eigenen Fans, lass es Neymar sein, lass es wen auch immer sein. Aber da tauschen sich halt dann quasi ein stinkreicher Club und ein anderer stinkreicher Club den Spieler. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es bei Dembele hatte man damals den Eindruck, als er von Dortmund zu, bei Neymar hatte man den Eindruck, dass quasi dieser Geldkreislauf so über mehrere Länder läuft. Dortmund hat dann Geld davon bekommen und letztlich kam dann auch ein bisschen was unten beim SC Freiburg an, jetzt vereinfacht gesprochen, weil die halt dann ihren Spieler Maximilian Philipp auch noch mal ein bisschen teurer verkaufen konnten. Bei Ronaldo bin ich mir diesmal nicht so sicher, muss ich sagen.
Ich finde den auch eben schwer, deswegen auch so schwer kategorisierbar, weil es ist halt einfach Cristiano Ronaldo und ich glaube Juve, das werden die logischerweise nie so sagen, aber klar ist das ein großer Antrieb. Die haben jetzt nicht nur einen der besten Spieler gekauft, sondern hat einfach eine der größten Sportmarken gekauft und das passt halt, glaube ich, auch. Das war genau das, was Juve wollte. Die haben sich in den letzten Jahren, wie gesagt, dem Pöa Pö da oben ran geschlichen, sage ich mal, ran geschnuppert und jetzt, glaube ich, haben sie gedacht und haben die Chance gesehen, dass jetzt die Zeit gekommen ist für diesen einen großen Knall, um plötzlich halt wirklich von einem Tag auf den anderen auch auf dieser sehr, sehr großen Bühne zu sein. Und dass sie das hinbekommen haben, dass sie da die richtigen Fäden gezogen haben, das, glaube ich, liegt eben viel an Agnelli, auch an Marotta. Und ja, wie sich das dann sportlich entwickelt, wird sich dann zeigen.
Beobachten und alle Rechteinhaber der Serie A freuen sich jetzt schon, dass da jetzt mehr Aufmerksamkeit drauf liegt. Vorletzte Frage – wer hatte die Sieben bei Juve?
Die Sieben hatte Juan Cuadrado.
Und wie lief das so?
Und der hat überraschenderweise noch am selben Tag einen Tweet abgesetzt, wo er sagt, er freut sich sehr und er wird logischerweise auch sehr gern die Nummer Sieben überlassen, was sehr überraschend kann.
Ja, unglaublich.
Was hat er jetzt? Ich habe noch gar nicht gehört, was er jetzt an Neues hat, aber seit gestern gehen die Cristiano Ronaldo sieben Trikots über den Ladentisch. 104 Euro kostet das normale anscheinend. Es gibt aber ein Authentic-Trikot, das kostet dann 144, 95 Euro. Angeblich können sie sich jetzt schon nicht retten vor Anfrage und Vorverkauf.
Das wäre nämlich die letzte Frage gewesen, ob man schon weiß, wie viele Trikots verkauft sind. Das sieht man halt. Der Fußball ist eine Emotion, die man verkaufen kann, die man zu Geld machen kann. Dann kann man das natürlich doof finden, aber es funktioniert auch. Es hat ja auch dazu geführt, dass hier im Rasenfunk mitten in 1.000 WM-Sendungen eine Cristiano-Ronaldo-Folge gemacht wird. Also irgendwie machen ja auch alle dabei mit.
Um den Kreis da noch zu schließen, ich habe mir extra noch die Userzahlen von Juve gestern nach Mittag angeschaut. Als es rauskam, habe ich heute noch mal draufgeschaut und es gab heute auch schon Mitteilungen aus Italien. Angeblich seit gestern 17.30 Uhr, sogar 18 Uhr ungefähr, als es war bis heute Mittag, hat Juve schon eine Million Follower mehr auf diversen Kanälen. Ich bin bei dir, da kann man jetzt logischerweise sagen, ja, was hat das mit Fußball zu tun? Nein, nicht sehr viel, mit dem was auf dem Rasen passiert, aber aus Sicht eines modernen Fußballvereins, der halt auf Profit halt auch aus ist, ist es, glaube ich, nicht die unkleverste Idee, die man machen konnte.
Stimmt und jetzt habe ich doch noch eine letzte Frage, weil das Fußball so verkauft wird, liegt ja auch daran, das ist ja auch nichts Schlimmes. Also es lenkt ja auch die Leute ein bisschen ab. Es ist ein schöner Zeitvertreib und es leckt auch ab von eigenen Problemen. Glaubst du, dass es auch dahingehend in Italien jetzt mal außerhalb des Fußballs auch eine gewisse Bedeutung haben kann, dieser Wechsel, dass man – also es wird sich jetzt nicht gleich ein ganzes Land wieder im Selbstbewusstsein fühlen als – man ist wieder wer, aber gerade die Deutschen schauen ja immer sehr herab auf Italien, gerade die deutschen Medien und Italien hat aber natürlich auch, so wie ganz ganz viele Nationen, gerade wirtschaftliche und sonstige Probleme. Glaubst du, es kann auch dahingehend ein bisschen eine Auswirkung haben?
Also es wird zumindest, das merkt man jetzt schon, kann man wirklich sagen, seit gestern Abend, es wird so ein bisschen suggeriert auch in der Öffentlichkeit, auch transportiert von den Medien definitiv. Es wird gesprochen vom größten Sport-Coup der italienischen Geschichte und so und logischer Weise, du sprichst das ja an, gerade ist ja auch ein Thema, der italienische Fußball in Italien ist sehr präsent. Das wird vielleicht manchmal im Ausland immer an den Zuschauerzahlen gemessen, aber wenn man in einer italienischen Großstadt ist, wenn man in Italien am Strand ist, dann gibt es in erster Linie ein großes Thema und das ist Fußball. Und das gab es schon vorgestern Nachmittag und jetzt explodiert das halt einfach alles noch mal mehr. Und wie du sagst, das wird logischerweise auch so geredet, dass er jetzt halt auch für die jungen, für die kleinen italienischen Jungs, die jetzt in kleine Fußballschulen kamen, die schauen jetzt zu Cristiano Ronaldo auf. Die haben vielleicht davor ja auch schon zu Cristiano Ronaldo aufgeschaut. Richtig, genau. Und dann haben sie ihn einmal in der Champions League gesehen, als er in Turin gespielt hat oder in Rom. Jetzt spielt er jeden Samstag, jeden Sonntag auf einem italienischen Fußballplatz. Und ich kann das jetzt logischerweise nicht abschätzen, was das genau bringt, in welche Richtung es geht. Aber es wird schon so transportiert, dass das vielleicht auch wirklich eine Nummer sein könnte, von der zumindest die italienische Sportbewegung, sag ich mal – und wir wissen ja, wie wichtig heutzutage der Sport auch als gesellschaftliche eingeflochten ist – dass das auch da durchaus kleine Einflüsse haben könnte.
Ja, Wahnsinn. Unglaublich. Ein Wechsel und dann ging er auch noch so schnell über die Bühne und ohne irgendwelche Minora Jolas, die da noch ganz, ganz lange ihr Theater machen. Das lief diesmal ein bisschen anders. Christian, vielen Dank, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst und mir das alles erklärt hast.
Ja, Max, vielen Dank dir.
Wann bist du endlich bei Twitter?
Ich merke, der Druck wird größer.
Der Druck wird wirklich größer. Die Leute wollen die Huldigen öffnen.
Ich muss schauen, wie ich mich dem noch entziehen kann oder wie ich das Ganze am besten managere. Aber es steht auf dem Plan und mal schauen, was dabei rumkommt.
Ich werde die Frage einfach jedes Mal stellen, wenn du hier bist. Danke dir, dass du da warst. Und wo wir schon bei großen Zahlen jetzt die ganze Zeit in diesem Kurzfass waren, man kann auch den Rasenfunk unterstützen. Der Rasenfunk ist werbefrei, sponsorenfrei, allein von euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern, finanziert. Wie das geht, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen. Und ein herzliches Dankeschön an all diejenigen, die es jetzt schon tun. Ja, und ansonsten hören wir uns morgen wieder in einem WM-Kurzpass und es gibt morgen ein Tribügengespräch zur FIFA. Das passt irgendwie auch ganz gut in den Kontext. Wir hören uns morgen wieder. Macht's gut!